make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and
over at pop culture explained i told
everybody that i was going to make a
video on the dark hold explained but
something that i want to clarify here
because some people have asked this and
rightfully so
whether or not pop culture explained and
comics explain are exceedingly similar
not really so comics explain this is a
comic book channel
and one of the things that i've wanted
to focus on here recently was to create
a clear delineation between
focusing on like geek culture slash
movies and stuff like that
and focusing on comics because i want to
expand the overall kind of
uh explained brand right i mean i don't
want to be like fine bros and
copyrighted i think that's a stupid
decision
in terms of expanding the idea of like
explaining things um i want comics
explained to focus
exclusively on comics and nothing else
right it's only ever really comics
the only exception of that might be if i
like react to a trailer right like an
amazing trailer drops and i make like a
little video for it as i've done before
but in terms of talking about like comic
book themed movies
tv shows stuff like that that's what pop
culture explained is for the other thing
we do there is we actually explain like
a bunch of celebrities and stuff like
that right we're
kind of trying to figure out what works
what all you guys are interested in
because
trying to figure out what you guys like
is a very difficult task for a youtuber
it really is just trial and error but
that's an explanation that i wanted to
get out there right comments explained
is only just comics and that's it and so
in this video what i want to do here is
i want to explain the darkhold concept
within marvel comics now
the dark hole originally appeared back
in marvel spotlight number four
in 1972 and it was created by jerry
conway
and mike plute but here's the thing to
understand marvel's spotlight
back in the 1970s was an idea that was
created by stan lee and is what what's
basically called a test bed or a tryout
comic and what this means is that when
marvel was off to the races right when
they were just huge after like
spider-man the fantastic four the x-men
the avengers and stuff like that
it became pretty obvious that it was
very expensive to try their hand at
releasing a comic
if it failed right it just didn't really
sell there's the cost of printing the
comic the cost of getting it shipped out
the the cost of
advertising it all that kind of stuff
there was a lot that went into it and so
when stan lee became the president and
publisher of marvel he had this great
idea of saying okay let's bring back the
anthology series like the old action
comic stories when superman first showed
up or the old detective comic stories
you know dc showcase did the exact same
thing you know back in the
1950s when they first introduced mary
allen and let's basically create a
series of books where all we do
is introduce people to characters and
teams based on those books
and we use a combination of book sales
as well as fan write-ins to determine
whether or not that book is popular it's
why the amazing spider-man appeared in
amazing fantasy
because it was a test bed back at that
point in time marvel didn't know if it
was gonna
work it turned out to be one of the best
choices they ever made and spider-man
got his own solo series but nonetheless
focusing on the dark hole
the way this plays out is that in the
early days of marvel comics looking to
silver surfer annual number two in the
early days of marvel comics
what you had was an earth that was
occupied by the elder gods
now these elder gods came into existence
by way of a guy who was known as
the demiurge and the dimmier just kind
of like the sentience of
all of earth's ecosystems more or less
and so he spawned almost every concept
on earth that we're aware of so like
gaia who's basically like mother earth
in marvel comics was born
from demiurge when demiurge came into
existence that he kind of took his
essence his life force more or less and
spread it throughout the world which
gave birth in the form of these elder
gods who were these wildly powerful
cosmic beings
but as time went on the elder gods
basically devolved
into evil right they basically just
became these these
terrible evil beings the only ones who
didn't were ashtur
and gaia but because everybody else had
fallen the most powerful of the evil
elder gods was basically catholic and so
what you ended up having was in order to
purge the earth of these evil elder gods
and then in turn
give earth the ability to actually
create life-sustaining beings so humans
and animals and so on and so forth and
to turn it into a legitimately habitable
planet
gaia ended up beseeching demiurge to
give her the ability to have a child
which he did
who became known as a tomb and this
child basically transformed into what
was called the demogorge or the god
eater
and quite literally consumed all these
different elder gods across the entirety
of earth now some of these elder gods
were not consumed and they basically
just ended up fleeing catholic was one
of those he took off to his own
dimension
and basically has resided there ever
since but before he left he created what
were called the scrolls of cathone which
are basically just
all the knowledge and information he had
on his abilities to manipulate dark
magic that could be put on earth and
then used as a vessel for his return at
some future point in time meaning if
somebody were to pick up the dark hole
and start reading it assuming that they
were somebody who was compatible with
his ability to come back that he'd be
able to possess
them and then ultimately cast a spell
that would allow his
him to enter the the earthly realm in a
proper form that person of course we
know
to be the scarlet witch right she's kind
of the person that was prophesized to be
the vector by which
uh catholic would ultimately come back
now it's never really happened in marvel
comics it's come close a couple times
and the closest we ever actually got to
that in marvel was during the secret
empire event when she was fully
possessed by catholic up to that point
she was possessed like momentarily or it
was for a short amount of time and
almost cast the spell so like beast of
the x-men for example basically stopped
the whole thing from happening and like
saved wanda and he's tried to make his
way back a couple times but it was never
really anything of any
major significance i don't think in
comparison to the events of secret
empire but the important thing here is
that this
series of spells and so on were
originally written in flesh and it
remained that way
for quite some time in marvel comics now
one of the big things that happened out
of this really came by way of the second
host and the reason why i say that is
because for those of you guys who are
not familiar with what the hosts are in
marvel comics that if the elder gods
came into existence and then were
ultimately destroyed that life itself
just simply began to evolve as we would
normally expect it to right now there's
been
different iterations in marvel comics as
to how humans came into existence but no
matter how you slice it humans began to
come into existence and so when humans
began to evolve you had the arrival of
the celestials on earth who basically
split a group of humans
into thirds and then you know
manipulated their genes and that's where
you get the eternals the deviants and
that's where mutants come from
and so what ended up happening is that
uh when in the early days of human
existence the kingdom of atlantis served
as like this major trading hub
on earth right so imagine like we here
on the planet earth all go to atlantis
whenever we want to like trade stuff or
build up our empires and different
things like that and so what it
basically led to was this being
a massive kingdom now this basically
meant that humans were ultimately
subjugated by deviants and the eternals
just kind of abandoned their role as
people who were supposed to protect
humans from the deviants this led to the
celestials showing up a second time
to examine their experiments right to
see if the eternals had lived up to the
the role they were supposed to play to
see what became of the deviants and to
see whether or not the genes of baseline
humans had manifested into developing
powers when they showed up they realized
nothing was what it was supposed to be
right the deviants were basically
supposed to die off relatively fast they
didn't they just kept on living on they
enslaved humans and eternals hit a ban
in their role of protecting humans and
so what ended up happening was that
during this second host the deviants
attacked the celestials and the
celestials in turn
wiped out most of the deviants and then
sunk atlantis in what's called the great
cataclysm which you'll probably see
referenced in the eternals film uh the
the eternals themselves were so
terrified of what had happened that
either some of them fled earth entirely
or they went back to their role of
protecting humans like they were
supposed to
and then ultimately left earth right and
then settled on saturn's moon titan and
that's where you get thanos and his
brother eros of course all that stuff's
covered in like the thanos rising
storyline
uh the original eternals run by uh jack
kirby
it's the the whole idea of the great
cataclysm and the second host the
deviancy turtles all that kind of stuff
is kind of scattered all over the place
the meat and potatoes
are in jack kirby's original eternals
run but his original runs kind of been
retold
multiple times over the years by
different writers and reinterpreted so
you can kind of take it for what it's
worth but the important thing here
is that the dark holders were basically
people who served
a guy by the name of thulsa doom and
thul sudoom was essentially just like an
enemy of conan the barbarian
and coal from back in the day but the
the thing about this was that following
the defeat of thulsa doom
and his essential destruction what they
had done is they had taken the darkhold
as it existed at the time in the form of
just basically being written
being written in flesh and they took a
guy by the name of vernet
and then transformed him into the first
vampire now
following the great cataclysm varnet had
essentially just gone underground right
he had just gone dormant he had spawned
a series of vampires but all the other
vampires except for him had basically
died and so when he re-emerged again uh
during the hiborian age which is about
10 000 bc
uh he basically started creating more
vampires across the world and that's
where vampires come from in marvel
comics
werewolves also come from the dark hole
and that's largely how the dark hole
existed throughout marvel comics
is one of these things where it would
just pop up occasionally and be used by
a particular group to achieve a
particular goal
not fully understanding what it was that
they were doing but in terms of the dark
hole becoming what we know it today
which is to say
no longer being a concept that was
recorded over the course of scrolls or
flesh and in turn being transcribed into
book form
that came from morgan le faye so to kind
of wind things back a little bit prior
to the sinking of atlantis morgan le
faye
was a woman who was basically supposed
to be trained in a place called the
house of virgins
and she was supposed to become what they
referred to as a sea princess all that
really meant
is that she would essentially be trained
to become a witch is really all it meant
uh but she resided on the the island of
avalon now of course avalon a lot of you
guys know as the king arthur mythos but
alongside her or at least
in her general vicinity was a guy by the
name of miradan now miradan had become
aware or at least you know learned of
these prophecies of what would become
the great cataclysm so the second host
of the celestials obliterating
the kingdom of atlantis and sinking it
and so what ended up happening is that
in the aftermath of all of that
morgan lafaye and miradin ended up on
the isle of britain now ultimately the
island of avalon survived as well and
was eventually moved to the other world
right so just that's where like king
arthur and all those guys
basically occupied after their escapades
in britain proper but what you ended up
having here was
miradin changing his name to merlin and
then morgan lafaye basically going on to
become
essentially a villain now what ended up
happening here is morgan le faye along
with the dark holders had basically
intended to resurrect uh cathode or
bring cathode
into the earthly realm and then force
him to do the bidding for them right to
help them achieve their own goals
because they were looking to topple
merlin and that kind of stuff
ultimately catholic was simply too
powerful for them to contain and so
before he could be completely
unleashed onto earth what ended up
happening is that uh morgan lafaye
basically took the spirit or the essence
of catholic and then
stuck him inside wonder gore mountain
where he remained essentially ever since
now this became important because of the
fact that over the years different
things had taken place where different
people had like copied the dark hold
text different people had discovered
these copies
or like different versions were made or
something similar to it like the
necronomicon or something along those
lines but the actual book of the
darkhold did kind of pass from person to
person but cathone being stuck inside
the of wondergore mountain became
significant because
as we know from our x-men history that
we've talked about here on comics
explained
so many times before uh that in the
aftermath of world war
ii that uh eric eric lyncher and magda
ended up moving to you know moving out
to eastern europe more or less and
settling down and having a daughter
anja now when anya was killed by the
town's people and eric's powers
manifested for the first time
and then he started calling himself
magneto magda took off running
i'm completely unaware of the fact that
she was pregnant with twins pietro and
wanda maximoff and so she took up
residence in one de gore mountain and
ultimately gave birth to the twins
there was this great big huge crazy
series of stories that marvel did where
they tried to like reveal the fact that
that
quicksilver and scarlet witch were
actually magneto's kids that was the
original
vision and scarlet witch series written
by bill
matlow and then they tried to go back
and undo it and all that kind of stuff
but nonetheless what's important here is
that when wanda was born in one dagor
mountain that catholic picked up on her
birth and realized how powerful she
would become
that she was the perfect person for him
to enter into the earthly plane and so
she was
touched with a portion of catholic's
power so that when her when she
developed her abilities she would
basically learn how to use what was
called chaos magic or the magic that was
part and parcel dicathon himself making
her one of the most powerful beings to
ever exist in the history of marvel
comics when she was at her peak right
when it was house of m
scarlet witch but as for the dark hole
itself again it's kind of passed from
location to location
even people like the high evolutionary
the guy who basically ran one to gore
mountain and the person that magda took
up residence with while she was giving
birth to the twins a guy
you know this guy basically just focuses
on like speeding up people's evolution
he's mastered his own evolution he's
almost demi god powerful he's a super
powerful character uh but it just kind
of passed to him
it's passed to doctor doom it's been
used by a multitude of different people
right during the rise of the midnight
suns you had a you had the book
reappearing right so
it's appeared multiple times more
recently it was a big event during the
the carnage saga and i can actually
cover that if you guys are interested
but for the dark hole the the long and
short of this is that this is a book
that contains all the powerful
spells and incantations that belong to
catholic and those individuals who can
harness the power of the dark hold and
use it effectively without being
corrupted by it can become incredibly
powerful the problem with this
is it's incredibly difficult to use the
book and not become controlled by it not
become manipulated by it and basically
becoming a subservient of catholic
because catholic is always looking to
return to the earthly plane and so if
you or i put
picked up the book with no magical
prowess whatsoever and we were not
powerful enough to overcome the
influence of catholic he would seize
control of us
and then have us carry out his bidding
whatever that bidding happens to be
which is usually trying to find some way
to bring him back into the earthly plane
but again it's a pretty powerful
artifact it just it
doesn't show up a ton in any real
meaningful way in marvel comics i mean i
guess it does show up a lot but not for
any real meaningful moments it just has
a few things here and there the real big
thing that really comes to the dark hole
is cathode that's where a lot of the
meat and potatoes is focused when it
comes to those particular stories that
involve the dark hole itself now we have
seen it appear
in like the marvel related television
shows so it was an agents of shield it
was in the runaways
and of course you know we also know
where it's appeared as well or at least
seems to have appeared as well
in uh in the marvel cinematic universe
so it's a cool concept you know what
marvel will do with it i don't know
i really have no earthly clue what
they're going to do with this book i
think they'll end up doing quite a few
things and i think it'll actually become
pretty significant
in the realm of doctor strange we know
that like to a degree there seem to be
aspects of it right the book of of
kaiselius which is basically the the
book that we saw in doctor strange one
uh which seemed to basically take pages
from the darkhold but was not actually
the darkhold itself
uh this is definitely one of those books
where if it does exist in the marvel
cinematic universe
doctor strange would be smart to lock it
away under every conceivable spell he
can think of and make sure
nobody could ever get their hands on it
because if the wrong person gets their
hands on it they're going to unleash
cthunk and if you guys thought thanos
with the infinity gauntlet is bad he has
nothing on cathone whatsoever not even
not even not even close right
not one bit not even a little bit so
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end uh if you
guys are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you